Have you ever been watching a movie or a TV
show and you saw an actor doing a thing that
you know a lot about and they are just not
doing it right?
Well, we have and that thing we know a lot
about is microscopy.
And there are plenty of examples out there
of movies and TV shows that get microscopy
right, and then there are others that show
a scientist looking through a microscope that
has no objectives attached to it.
And yes, that's a real example of something
we've seen in a TV show.
But instead of just sitting there, wanting
to shout at the screen, we have decided that,
exclusively for our Patreon patrons, we’re
going to record a Microcosmos Reacts video
where some members of our team will be reacting
to some good and not-so-good movie microscopy.
But we will only make this video if we hit
our current goal of 900 monthly patrons!
So, if you would like to support this channel
and help us hit our goal so we can make that
video, you can head on over to patreon.com/journeytomicro.
And please let us know in the comments below
if you have any favorite movies and TV shows
that have done microscopy either really well
or really bad.
The organism here is one of the more unusual-looking
microbes we’ve seen in the microcosmos.
In fact, calling it an organism seems strange.
It looks more like a coral reef painted by
an artist inspired by both Gustav Klimt
and a pile of trash.
And if you saw that painting hanging in a
museum, you might pass it by without thinking
much of its subject.
In the middle of the 19th century, an
organism that looked a bit like this one did
a terrible thing.
It could not know that it was doing
something terrible of course.
It had recently arrived in a new land, and
all it sought was some food.
But in the process, it starved a nation and
killed many people.
The organism was a type of water mold called
Phytophthora infestans, which made its
way from North America to Ireland.
And with its arrival came the Great Famine.
Phytophthora infestans infected potato and
tomato plants, producing lesions on the leaves
and stems, and appearing as a white growth
along the lesions.
The infected crops rotted, making them inedible.
Phytophthora infestans belongs to a group
of organisms called oomycetes, which translates
to “egg fungus.”
And we’ve actually encountered another destructive
member of this family before, early in our
journey through the microcosmos.
We recommend going and watching that video
because it’s still one of the oddest events
we’ve watched unfold under a microscope.
But what we’ve learned since then thanks
in part to oomycete expert Bill Fry from Cornell
University, is that we were watching a parasitic
oomycete that had managed to turn a Daphnia’s
egg into its own vehicle for reproduction.
On the rare occasion that we find oomycetes
in our samples, it’s almost always under
similar grim circumstances, where these strange
creatures have found a way to grow on the
bodies of dead bugs or crustaceans.
And we’re never entirely sure if they just
happened to stumble on a dying organism to
feed on, or if they were actually the cause
of death.
Now, there are free-living oomycetes that
don’t infect other organisms.
Instead, they feed on decaying life.
But as for the rest: an oomycete researcher
named Gordon Beakes once gave a talk titled
“natural born killers”.
And if you go through a list of oomycetes,
you start to realize just how well-earned
that name is.
There’s Aphanomyces astaci, which has wiped
out populations of European crayfish.
There’s Phytophthora ramorum, which took
down oak trees in California.
There’s grapevine-targeting Plasmopara viticola,
the maize-infecting Peronosclerospora philippinensis,
the list goes on and on, affecting everything
from soybeans to chocolate production.
And none of this sounds that out of character
for a group of organisms collectively called
“egg fungus,” right?
There are fungi that like to eat dying things,
and there are fungi that like to infect plants.
We’ve even witnessed murderous fungi at
work here in the microcosmos, weaving their
web around unsuspecting nematodes.
So oomycetes are just one more of these fungi,
their filamentous structures helping them
spread their bodies as they prepare spores
that will help them spread even further.
Except, oomycetes are not fungi.
Their walls are not made of chitin the same way
fungi walls are, and their nuclei have two
copies of genetic information compared to
the fungi’s singular copy.
Instead, it turns out that oomycetes are members
of a different group of organisms called Stramenopiles,
making oomycetes more closely related to diatoms
and brown algae than they are to fungi.
And it’s strange to think about it in these
terms.
Diatoms are about as close as you can get
to pacifists in the microcosmos.
They enclose themselves in silica walls and
photosynthesize to make their own food.
It’s like oomycetes are killers turning
up to a family reunion full of hippies who
spend their days churning sunshine into sugar.
You can’t help but look at them and ask,
“How did you turn out like that?”
Well this certainly wouldn’t
be the first time two
very unrelated organisms share
an uncanny resemblance.
Birds and bats and bees all have wings, but
the wings do not make them closely related.
These animals just went through their own
histories of adaptation and survival, and
in the process converged upon the same idea.
And there’s probably some degree to which
oomycetes and fungi experienced something similar.
They both happened upon a form and lifestyle
that parasitized and infected, profiting on
the decay that results.
But at some point, something strange happened.
The supposedly-parallel paths of oomycetes
and fungi intersected, sparking collaboration.
Or rather, oomycetes copied fungi.
The process by which oomycetes did this is
called horizontal gene transfer, which allows
genetic material to move from one organism
to another through some means that is not
reproduction.
It’s pretty common in prokaryotes, but as scientists
have learned through oomycetes, eukaryotes
can go through horizontal
gene transfer as well.
As part of our ongoing battle with oomycetes,
scientists have had to get well-acquainted
with their genes.
And as they studied these sequences, they
found that some of the species, particularly
the plant-infecting species, had genes whose
origins had to have come from fungi through
horizontal gene transfer.
In Phytophthora ramorum, the oomycete that
kills oak trees, scientists estimated that
7.6% of the proteins released by the organism
are produced from genes that originally came
from fungi.
Some of these copied genes have given oomycetes
the ability to break down plant cell walls.
Others may help the oomycetes combat plant
defenses.
Based on our look through the research on
horizontal gene transfer from fungi to oomycetes,
it’s not clear what the process actually
looks like.
That information makes horizontal
gene transfer seem like some arcane biological
magic, bringing together two organisms that
superficially resemble each other and making
them related without making them family.
Meanwhile, in the world around us, spores
spread and take hold of dead insects
and soon-to-be-dead plants.
And buried in their bodies is the evidence
of the unusual collaboration that has made
them so deadly, an incomplete answer to the
question,
“How did you get this way?”
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
If you’re interested in fungi that’s a
little less micro, you should check out this
video from our sibling channel PBS Eons, all
about the giant, ancient fungi that once ruled
the world.
And while you’re over there, you should
also subscribe and check out the rest of their
videos, where they will take you on a journey
through the history of life on Earth.
You can find the giant fungi video, and much
much more at youtube.com/eons
The folks on the screen right now, they are
our Patreon patrons.
They're the people who make it possible for
us to make this show.
And also they've gotten us almost all the
way to 900 patrons.
And when we get there, we will make that video
reacting to wonderful and terrible screen microscopy.
So they've gotten us most of the way there.
But if you want to help get us all the way
there, you can do that by going to patreon.com/journeytomicro.
If you want to see more from our master of
microscopes, James Weiss, you can check out
Jam and Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there's
probably a subscribe button somewhere nearby.